(can clicks open)
- Ah.
- [Interviewer] All right, Yolanda.
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] Yolanda.
Where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- [Yolanda] I grew up in
Los Angeles, Echo Park.
- [Interviewer] Echo park.
And tell me about your childhood.
You had both your parents growing up.
- [Yolanda] No, I didn't.
My dad was in prison
because it was a vehicular manslaughter.
He killed my mom
in a vehicle accident,
and they were drinking.
On Father's Day.
It was a prison, being in prison.
- [Interviewer] So your mom died.
- My mom died.
I was 1 years old at the time.
So we were raised by my dad's parents.
And we thought those were my parents.
So he came out of prison
and he was like this big old, scary guy.
And we didn't know he was our dad.
- [Interviewer] So you were
raised by your grandparents?
- My dad's parents, yeah my grandparents.
- [Interviewer] Tell me
about your childhood.
How would you describe it?
- My childhood was, as a middle child.
I was left out a lot.
- It was average, but I
was very rebellious person.
I was really. I would
climb out the window.
I started using acid.
I started using drugs at
like 14, and selling drugs
like when I was 15, 16.
And it just became a lifestyle for me.
And, um...
But when I got pregnant with my son.
I thought it would change.
It never changed.
I got pregnant by my son
by an older man who was 27 years old.
He was from the Hell's Angels.
And before I realized that I was pregnant.
I watched him get killed on TV from LAPD.
Cause he was from the Hell's
Angels and pulled them over.
I guess he beat them up and ran
and he started shooting
and they killed him.
Up there on Highland Park.
That's when I found out he was married.
(Yolanda snort laughs)
When I found out.
So she didn't let me go
see him at the hospital.
She just swore up and down
that was not his child.
But,
it didn't mean his child, she did come
and see him when he, when I had him.
And she's like, yup.
That's Butch, because his name was Butch.
- [Interviewer] And you were how old
when you got pregnant?
- I was 17.
- [Interviewer] 17.
- 17.
- [Interviewer] So did you finish school?
- No
I went up to the 11th grade,
but I was a continuation.
I was a continuation because
I was always ditching,
drinking,
going to ditching parties.
- [Interviewer] So now you're 17.
You have child.
- I'm 17.
I've just had a child, and um...
My family just took over.
They started raising
him and all that stuff
because I was still,
I guess, not ready to be a mom.
My sister took over, my
grandparents took over.
But bottom line is that my
son loved me unconditionally.
No matter what I did.
And no matter where I
was and no matter what,
who said what, they could never
talk bad in front of my son.
When he got,
at the age of 9, 10, he got
he got caught in the system
and that's when he became
hard.
He just had to, he grew up to
be a man real fast, you know.
At 14, he already had like a little beard
and stuff like that.
But I used to go see him all the time.
But he was very angry with me.
He was really, really mad at me because
of the fact that he was
living in a foster home.
He didn't understand what was going on,
but it made him hard.
And that's how he got
into gangs and stuff.
You know, he became real hard.
- [Interviewer] So your
son became a gang member.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] These are Hispanic gangs?
- He became an underground,
hit man.
- [Interviewer] A hit man.
For which gang?
- Um.
(audio cuts out)
And he was really like,
nobody knew his business.
The only way I found out
was because after he died
his homeboys came and told
me what it was all about.
There was a gang,
that put a 187 on him
because he had like a
shootout with one of the kids.
And one of the kids was their son.
And I knew their parents.
So my son carried a big old shotgun
with a trench coat at 102 degrees.
I knew there was something wrong.
And you had 187 on him.
But what happened was that
before that was lifted,
the guy that put the 187 on him
ended up being shot in the head
at 3 o'clock in the afternoon
at an ARCO station.
We're gonna find out later on that...
That's how I found out that it was like,
it was like a hit.
And I was always already, Why
you wanting all this money,
all this money.
I didn't know until after he passed away,
the real truth.
But it's best that I didn't know.
Because he always carried guns with him.
It was always a 45 Smith and Western.
But when I seen him
with a sawed-off shotgun
I knew there was something
really seriously wrong.
I knew he was doing something.
He came to me to tell me, go talk to
see if these parents,
being around blah, blah.
You know, and I did.
I told him, you guys
need me to brick house.
You know, if I burned that
house down or something happens
to my son and I've burned it down.
The brick house is not
going to fall down and it's
going to burn everybody up.
This is what I told him because
my son was being threatened
with it, with the 187, or something.
That there's some way.
And when I pursued whatever
it was, I just know
that I had to protect my son.
But it turned out that,
catching a major case,
by the grace of God.
The guy came and just
dropped all the cases,
all the charges.
And I took him to Canyon Country.
And that's when...
I really don't know what
really happened to this day.
- [Interviewer] So your son passed away.
Was he your only child?
- [Yolanda] No. I have my daughter of '88.
And my daughter.
Yeah
My daughter.
When my son went into the system,
my sister suggested that
I have my daughter go stay
with my cousin, which
she couldn't have kids.
And in the long run, I
was fighting for her.
But my cousin was really being,
I mean I couldn't understand
cause she was blood, she's blood family.
But she wouldn't bring
her to the visitations.
She would say that I didn't
go to the visitation.
That I wouldn't make
the appointments, the
schedules, and wouldn't call.
I would make no contact
with my...
well it turned out that I went to prison.
I got a 6 year term and went to VSPW.
It was in that term.
Marsha, she told me that she got pregnant
at 13 years old.
And then I was hearing
that she was running away
from home and climbing
out the window and like...
Well, if she had it so good there.
Why is she keep running away?
Why is she running away out the window?
Why is she?
But what happened was that after my 6,
my daughter passed away.
She passed away in 2017
at 28 years old.
Um,
She got hit by a train.
And a drink of water, identified her.
But my son, she had my son's
name, her brother's name.
And that's how we identified her.
Cause she had her brother's
name tattooed on her, you know.
But,
when I seen my grandson
and I see her stepfather
it was
no denying
that they were father and son.
- [Interviewer] That's
because she was being molested
by her stepdad.
- She was being molested by her stepdad.
Robert.
And, I always felt like
I need to go and do something,
press charges, do something,
kick his ass, shoot him in the leg.
Well, cut off his (bleeping)
dick or something.
That's how I felt that as
a mom, I need to do that
because of the fact is that
they took her to Arizona
and adopted her, on other
rules in different state.
Because here I would not going to say it.
But then when I found all that out,
when I found out she died.
And I,
my cousin told me about that stuff.
And I told him, he said
they knew everything about it.
That they knew that you kicked him out.
They wouldn't let him go there.
But he's, here he is in the funeral.
Oh, why did he take my spot?
When I'm the biological mom, you know?
So I decided to step
up and take my grandson
to the side and tell him,
do you know who I am?
He says, no.
I go, your mom is my daughter.
You always thought that
the one that raised her
my cousin and this
asshole was her parents.
But he didn't know.
He knew that I was George's
mom. Joyce's brother's mom.
But, he was assured that
that was the same dad.
You know what I mean?
But it wasn't.
But the fact it was the same mom.
And I told him, I told him that I was
his biological mom.
I was her biological mom
and you were my grandson.
And,
and do you believe that?
And this was in church, in the aisle.
And he said, yeah. He
goes, what do I call you?
I mean, you could call me grandma Yo-yo.
So when he seen us
talking, what happened was
after the services, we
got to know each other.
Cause I never seen at
14, he was 14 years old.
I never met him.
But that boy looked exactly like that man.
I wanted to cut his head
off or do something.
They would not let me.
But,
I feel like I need to
do something for her, in her honor.
Like, cause every time I asked her,
well who's the dad? Who got her pregnant?
She said she got gang raped.
She don't know who the dad is.
She just made up these stories.
And um,
they kind of like
kind of like pushed her out of the house.
Put her in a mental hospital.
They said she's crazy.
So that they could keep her
son and raise him as their own.
The same thing they did
to me, with my daughter.
They took me out of her
life just to keep her
and make her think that was mom and dad.
So that was really messed up.
- [Interviewer] So today
you're down here on skid row.
- I'm on skid row.
- [Interviewer] Where are you?
Where do you stay?
(Yolanda gulps)
- I stay on San Julian.
Ah, skid row housing and trust.
I've been there since
2012, my last prison term.
- [Interviewer] Are you using drugs today?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] What do you use?
- I smoke crack.
And I drink and I smoke weed.
But...
- [Interviewer] How do
you support yourself?
- I have an income and um...
I also,
I've been,
I've been hustling
crack for 15 years.
- [Interviewer] When you say hustling?
- That means, you know.
Selling it.
Buying it, selling it back.
And I was doing that,
big time.
But I got arrested.
For sales.
Direct sales. Sales of narcotics,
blah, blah, blah, blah.
And I did my time.
I did four 4 year terms
and one 6 year term.
But I did fire camp, fire department
fire camp abuse.
But still, it was time in prison that I
got used to. I guess I shouldn't say it.
I mean,
I have nothing else
because when I lost my son, I lost my job.
I lost my son.
I lost everybody thought that it was my...
My family thought that it was me,
was the reason for my son passing away.
Because we never had a
child die in our family.
That was a first time ever.
So that made me look really
bad because I'm the mom.
I'm a single mom, you
know, blah, blah, blah.
And, but my son, he kinda came like...
I want to say, he was 17 years old
and the coffins were
like too small for him.
He was like six foot three,
235 (bleeping) pounds.
He was a football frame at 16, 17.
So that right there was like, big loss.
And everybody, I have a really big family
and they just turned around
and after losing all that.
You would think family
would come in, and help.
Well, again, it happened that way.
They just looked at me
like, it's your fault that
your son should have never.
You're supposed to die before your son.
Blah, blah, blah, but whatever.
Now that my daughter died.
Now, whose fault is that right?
Well, she got, she didn't
get hit by a train directly.
What happened was that I remember
seeing it,
online, when they were
showing it on the news.
But I didn't really,
I didn't really trip that
it was my daughter, right.
But after it, after I realized
wait a minute.
I've seen that.
And the way they described it,
that had to be my daughter.
So she's walking down the track,
where the freight trains go.
Not,
not Metro link or nothing but freight.
And the conductor said in his statement
saying that they seen her
walking, her hair was down.
Her hair was really long.
And he was like,
blowing the horn.
And it seemed like she didn't even hear
to pay attention to it.
She was like, can you have no ID?
No, nothing.
Like she was just walking down.
So I guess the train kept going.
And,
at the end of the train,
the caboose
I guess it's bigger than
the train, the back of it.
And it hit her,
and it nicked her.
And it scooped her up
into the tracks.
Would have mangled her and everything so.
Identifying her, they had a
hard time identifying her.
But this what happened in like November.
That's like almost Thanksgiving
of 2017.
We didn't find out it was
her, till like December.
And then we had those
services. December 11th.
Cause my sister was going to pay for it.
But the Thursday before
that, before that day
my sister went into the
emergency room at Kaiser.
She's my only sister.
She went for some blood clogs.
They had an operation, she went into ICU.
She was in ICU intensive care.
So that Saturday or Sunday,
I went to go see her.
And it was unbelievable to
see my sister like that.
She's just like always been to work.
Well, what happened was that she told me,
Oh, don't look like I'm going
to make Joyce's services,
her niece.
I know Becky.
And she...
I went to the Service's Monday.
And Tuesday morning, Tuesday afternoon
the next day at 3 o'clock.
They called me and told
me my sister passed away.
Not that we,
I mean, my sister.
She provided.
I was wanting, I was depending, she...
How do you call it? She put me under
tax return, stuff like that.
- [Interviewer] Has losing your children,
and your sister,
worsened your drug use or
your mood or depression or anything?
- It is worse.
It is worse because you
know, for real swirls,
I don't know what I'm living for.
Say, there's a purpose.
Why are you taking the people
that don't deserve to go?
What, I'm the one that
had that corrupt life?
The one that I've been
down here doing drugs.
This and that.
Just doing things that, at any time
your life could end.
For whatever reason it is...
Thank you.
But for whatever reason it is
I continue to have that big heart.
Just like right now,
my relationship is really
a very abusive relationship.
- [Interviewer] You're in
an abusive relationship now.
- Yes. I'm a victim of domestic violence.
I have restraining orders.
Protective orders from the judge.
And they gave me a reasonable
accommodation to move
out of the place that
I'm at to another place.
Because that person
seems to be able to have
that way to come in and out.
Anyway, anytime you want to.
And,
I mean, it's, I hit him.
Bang, bang, bang, bang, bang,
knock, I'm going to kick down.
Almost try to kick it.
And nobody says (bleep).
Nobody does, says nothing.
Nobody does nothing.
Nobody calls nobody, nothing.
Knowing how severe and how aggressive
that person is being.
You know what I mean?
And,
that's why I'm out here
at this time today because,
I have a place to live.
I have a place to go.
I'm not there because he's there.
And I don't want to be there.
- [Interviewer] Do you
think there's anything
from your childhood or
anything in your life
that kind of
created a lot of the dysfunction?
A lot of the tragedy that
you, your life has seen?
- I think learning about
the death of my
mom
and how my dad,
I mean nobody told us,
they made us think that
my grandparents were our parents.
When that man came into
our lives, it scared me.
It scared me because
he was very scary man.
- [Interviewer] Your dad.
- Yeah. My dad was a very scary man.
He looked like the chief,
like,
just a real big, ugly chief.
- [Interviewer] Are you American Indian?
- Yeah.
Yeah. I'm American Indian.
- [Interviewer] What tribe?
- Navajo tribe.
- [Interviewer] Navajo.
- Yeah. Originally...
- I'm here today on skid row.
(police siren wails in background)
I know a lot of people down here.
I have. People don't
have grudges against me.
The only thing they do is
they hate on me because
of my rapport.
Read on me.
When will you sell drugs down here?
And it's a good thing
and you do good and you treat people good.
And you don't forget about your peoples.
They don't forget about you.
And you really don't.
But it's just about that.
It's not all about that.
Then when I got my place, I don't need.
Ain't one person over
here that I didn't let him
come over and stay for you to,
washing, for clothes.
Take a shower.
I don't think there's one person
that I didn't do that for.
Because why not?
You know?
But just the relationship that, I mean.
He did a manslaughter
right across the street
where I lived, which I wasn't there yet
but this is what I heard
and he'd killed somebody
but the person didn't die
until he got to the hospital.
So it became a manslaughter.
So when he offered him
17 years and not life,
who's not going to snap, you
know, jump on that right.
So he did.
So whatever I made him
after he got out, not really met him.
It was more like just
getting high kind of thing.
And then that's when I had my accident
when I broke my femur bone.
And I went to the hospital
and had two major surgeries.
Got a titanium rod in my leg.
And it was funny that this man
that I know from a can of paint.
I just got out of prison, stood
there and took care of me.
Then that's when I got hurt.
And I met this guy.
It had turned out
that we got a little bit close,
and now this became abusive.
That's why I'm not even home right now.
And, as you could see,
if you could see my eye.
- [Interviewer] Yeah,
your eyes. Black and blue.
That's from him.
(interviewer sighs)
- Yep.
- [Interviewer] So what is
your biggest vice right now?
Is it alcohol or crack or what?
- Alcohol.
- [Interviewer] Alcohol is your big deal.
- Alcohol. Because,
I'm severe depression.
I got accepted for SSI, for my mental.
I thought it was gonna be physical.
I didn't think my mental was that bad.
I think the traumatizing of my children.
The traumatizing community
skid row and not be raised.
I'm going down here and just,
I'm just actually living
through this.
I've been here since, my daughter
around '88 when I came down here for sure.
And that's like,
long time.
- [Interviewer] You've had a rough life.
- Yeah. I had a rough life, but
at the same time it was like
I don't know what is a real life.
You know what I mean?
- [Interviewer] All right, Yolanda.
Thank you so much for sharing your story.
- You're welcome.
- [Interviewer] Good luck with
getting away from the guy.
- [Yolanda] Oh Yeah.
Yeah.
Oh, if it's not in this weekend.
I have to deal with.
Maybe I'll just get me a
room and stuff like that.
Just for the weekend.
By Monday, I literally have to be here.
Waiting for like an income verification.